We often see Elon Musk and his siblings
pictured with their mum, Maye Musk.
Yet their relationship with their
father is much more complicated.
Errol Musk is a brilliant engineer who undoubtedly
passed on his genes to his famous son.
He has also been described by Elon as “evil”.
This is the story of how he helped
shape the richest man in the world.
Errol was born in Pretoria, South Africa
to an army sergeant father and a British
mother whose family is famed for their intellect.
Errol and Maye grew up in the same neighborhood.
He fell for her supermodel looks.
She became a well-known
fashion model and a dietician.
The two dated on and off at university.
According to Maye, Errol relentlessly pursued
her hand in marriage, telling Elon’s biographer
Ashlee Vance, “He just never stopped proposing.”
Reminiscent of Elon’s pursuit
of his first wife Justine while
they were at university together in Canada.
Justine described to biographer Vance
how Elon would call her insistently,
saying, “You always knew it was Elon because
the phone would never stop ringing. The man
does not take no for an answer. You can’t blow
him off. I do think of him as the Terminator. He
locks his gaze on to something and says, ‘It
shall be mine.’ Bit by bit, he won me over.”
Nine months after Errol and Maye tied
the knot, Elon came into the world.
They knew their son was special from
a very young age as Errol told South
African radio station 702’s the
Money Show with Bruce Whitfield.
He’s always been a very deep thinker. When he
was very small, for example, he would ask me:
“Where is the whole world?”. Good question. It’s a
very good question, yah. I’m talking about when he
was three or four. And these sort of questions
made me realize he’s a little different.
The Musk family lived comfortably in Pretoria
thanks to Errol’s successful engineering business
and his work as a real-estate developer.
According to Elon, his father
has an extremely high IQ
and is a talented electrical
and mechanical engineer.
Elon benefited immensely from his father’s skill.
Errol used to take him and his brother
Kimbal to his engineering job sites
where they learned how to lay bricks, install
plumbing, and put in electrical wiring.
It was also Errol who introduced
Elon to the world of computers.
When Elon was 11, he insisted that his dad take
him to learn how to use the new
computers that had just come out.
He was far too young to attend a course hosted at
the University of the Witwatersrand
in Johannesburg
but his dad managed to book him a spot
through his engineering connections.
Errol recounted what happened
when Elon went to that lecture.
Anyway, he went, and I left him there, took Kimbal
and I went off to get a hamburger. And came back.
It was a three-hour-long thing at Wits. And we
came back and everyone came out and no Elon.
And we waited and waited. And finally, went
into the chilly halls of Wits and found this
sort of sloping theatre, lecture hall, rather.
And there was Elon with his jacket and tie off
and his sleeves rolled up and his long grey
flannels, four feet high, talking to all these
blokes from England. And when I walked up to
them, the one who, some professor - he didn’t even
bother to sort of introduce himself - he
just said to me: ‘This boy has to have one
of these computers.’ Anyway, we got him one of the
computers, and I got it at a discount, thank God.
With that computer, Elon
taught himself how to program.
And he was brilliant at it.
He scored an A+ on an aptitude test for
programming and operating a computer when
he briefly attended the University of Pretoria.
According to Maye, he had to be re-tested because
the university had never seen such a high score.
Although from the outside it may have
appeared Elon had a happy childhood,
he would say that it felt like
“misery” thanks in large part to Errol.
Maye and Errol divorced in
1979 when Elon was eight.
She left what she described
as an abusive relationship.
Maye struggled as a single mom. She said
she’d cry when one of the kids spilled milk
because she couldn’t buy more milk that day.
She worked several jobs to
support her three children,
bought secondhand clothes, and cooked cheap
and nutritious meals for them like bean stews.
After a couple of years, Elon felt
sorry that his father was living alone
and decided to move in with him
in a suburb of Johannesburg.
It was a decision he would come to regret.
Elon told Rolling Stone: “He
was such a terrible human being.
You have no idea. My dad will have a carefully
thought-out plan of evil. He will plan evil.”
“Almost every crime you can possibly think of,
he has done. Almost every evil thing you
could possibly think of, he has done.”
Elon never specified what
his father had allegedly done
but says he wasn’t physically violent toward him.
This is what we do know about Errol.
He once said he shot and killed
three people who broke into his home,
and was later cleared of all charges
on the grounds of self-defense.
He also had a child with his stepdaughter,
Jana Bezuidenhout, from another marriage.
He said his stepdaughter turned to him for
comfort after a breakup with her boyfriend,
and the child was conceived
“in the heat of the moment”.
Errol has spoken out against Elon’s portrayal
of him, telling the UK’s Daily Mail:
“‘Elon needs to grow up. He needs to get over
himself. I’m not going to hit back. I’m going
to wait until he comes to his senses. He’s
having a tantrum, like a spoilt child.”
By the time Elon came to live
with him after the divorce,
Errol claimed he was making a
lot of money in emerald mining.
Business Insider reported that Errol
owned half of an emerald mine in Zambia.
And in another Business Insider article,
Errol said: 'We had so much money
we couldn't even close our safe'.
But according to Elon, his father
didn’t own an emerald mine.
Elon tweeted that he had to work his way through
college, ending up with $100,000 in student debt,
and couldn’t afford a second
computer at his first company, Zip2.
He said when he emigrated from South Africa to
North America, he only had $2,000 in his pocket.
Elon’s goal was always to
end up in the United States,
the home of all the exciting
developments in technology.
To get to the States, he first went
to Canada, his mother’s birthplace.
Elon was just 17 years old when he arrived
in Canada, where he stayed with a cousin,
working on a farm in Saskatchewan.
He later made his way here to Toronto,
and also obtained passports for his mother,
brother, and sister to join him. They lived
for a time at 4000 Yonge St. in this rent-controlled apartment.
According to Maye, Elon slept on the couch.
His father did not wish him well.
In fact, Errol didn’t think his
son would make much of himself.
Elon said his father told
him he’d be back in South
Africa in three months and that he was an idiot.
That “idiot” went on to found and run
two of the most innovative and successful
companies in the world, Tesla and SpaceX.
Some have suggested that Musk’s image as the
savior of humanity, by accelerating the world’s
transition to sustainable energy, and by trying to
colonize Mars, might stem from his childhood pain.
Rolling Stone wrote: Somewhere in this trauma
bond is the key to Musk’s worldview – creation
against destruction, of being useful versus
harmful, of defending the world against evil.
Does his father now believe his son will succeed
and go where no man or woman has gone before?
Is Elon going to get to Mars? He is. I don’t
think there’s any doubt in it whatsoever.
Yet it’s unlikely Elon would take
his father along for the ride.
Their relationship remains strained.
Elon Musk is now the richest person
who has ever lived.
If you’d like even a
tiny sliver of what he earns, there’s a great
way to invest with my sponsor Masterworks.
Masterworks lets you invest in
multi-million-dollar paintings by Picasso,
Warhol, and other famous artists.
Just like buying shares in Tesla,
you’d buy shares in these artworks
that have been securitized by the SEC.
I was really excited about working
with Masterworks as I’m a huge fan
of art and try to collect what I can.
I absolutely fell in love with Monet’s
paintings in particular when I lived in
Paris and would roam around all the museums,
soaking in his famous Water Lillies works.
When Masterworks sells the art, you get your
portion of the proceeds - which worked
out to a 32% net return for those who
invested in Banksy's Mona Lisa and 31.7% for
investors in George Condo’s Staring into Space.
What’s great about investing in art is that it
protects you from the bull market we’re in.
Plus, the art market shows
no signs of slowing down.
Contemporary art has outpaced
the S&P in the last decade.
So it was no surprise that the Wall
Street Journal said “art is among
the hottest markets on earth right now”
If you’d like to diversify your portfolio
and join 250,000 people who have already
signed up for Masterworks, you can sign
up with my custom link in the description.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.